and we do have a guest in the studio
some seven congrats on your win thank
you so first uh tell me what you think
about this position uh I mean this game
was insane for me yeah we saw this game
so it did seem winning for weight but at
some point the computer was saying so we
started from here we're White Queen and
then all of this happened I actually
didn't see what happened here so all of
this happened you're probably the Ponder
enough
so all of wait so this is apparently is
very good
it's kind of a study like position
why is it so good it's so hard oh he
could have picked up the g75 for free
ah because you cannot go here this just
loses a queen
but is it so important to take this G7
Pawn probably for Queen F6 reasons later
oh so he missed it so he checked can get
five oh he didn't miss it no he took it
oh he shouldn't have taken it
so before
so
so I think moving this bishop was good
because
so it's not uh I guess the point is if
they're B5
G3 we can probably play Queen
E5
and then claim that this cannot move
just pick up the F3 Pawn oh okay
so I don't have a move for the key if I
go here you take I can just go 24 just
take the pawn oh yes okay you just want
to take the afterpan okay
oh so instead he took the pawn which is
not good
and then push the Palm Quin do one is a
nice move
oh so they can just hides here
and now we have this position so do you
think it's going to be a draw it's
probably the bishop will give up itself
36 Queen T1 it seems forced
can I if we block they just taken G yeah
it should be a draw and if I block
Ed that might be scary for White Queen
D5 and then that's fun
so for example if I is this sorry worst
case I can always go takes G3 I think
oh something like this yeah
does this and then
this is a perpetual
oh but here I don't even have a threat
right because this is blocking okay wow
crazy game
yeah this was a really wild game from
the beginning it was at some point it
was Rook against like four pawns and
yeah yeah it was a pretty insane
position all right let's take a look at
your game so you had a really nice win
look so you played
so you're white you're playing the
Berlin end game yeah I think he mixed up
plans here he played Bishop B7 with the
idea of Knight H4 and then he played H5
on the next move
um which usually people don't mix those
two right yeah we're also talking about
H5 and Julian was saying that usually
I'll pull on a plate should be six so
your king goes the other way okay so he
went Bishop at 4 H5
rookie one
yeah basically uh yeah take 692 is nice
and I want to play Knight D4 here
uh followed by E6 and he played A6
really quickly to stop Knight D4 yeah
but he missed that I can go E6 yeah this
is very thematic for the structures and
he has to take with the bishop we talked
about this so now C7 is hanging yeah so
the interesting part was this uh Rook
end game that we reached
so in this position
like what did you think of your chances
I thought maybe instead of Rook takes B7
I should have taken control over of the
D5 with Rook D1
ah also playing and then just bring the
king to E3
so I think there's really good technical
chances here King goes to E3 and Black's
Pat Rook is so passive so he has to
Defenders he can still play P5 because I
can't do K7 yet then I bring my king
over
was kind of risky by me
but it's still very difficult to defend
for black he started off doing the right
move so Rook D2 is fine rookie Rook D6
is good rookie two is good yeah this was
really nice I think he has to go A5
it's the safest move uh we're thinking
of just waiting that's what he played oh
that is what yeah not to allow you A5
because now it becomes really difficult
for him and in this position what do you
think about C5 I was considering Rook 66
Rook 66
B4 I think Rook D3 only yeah it's B5
takes takes I'm not sure I think I have
good chances here
so here at Rook B1 yes uh put the Rook
on eight yeah yeah we're looking at this
and there was some kind of uh just by
force who reached King and pawn end game
there was a drop but of course yeah I
think it's very hard to talk with this
yeah and I think a lot of these
questions also like if I pick up the C5
pawn and then play H4 GH Rook takes H5
that two versus one ending is pretty
unpleasant for black yeah
so so you think he shouldn't have a lot
so he should have played a five here a
rookie two is fine
yeah here I think A5 is a correct B4
uh the idea is now he goes Rook C2
uh so I was planning to play B3 instead
of B4
and plays C4 and just like stay solid
attacked upon an A5 or k6 uh still
definitely difficult for black but in
the game
after A5
Rook D5 Rook C6 Rook A5 I found this
really nice move H4 yeah I thought H1
was really nice uh apparently black can
hold but that's just take
take a rookie one
I was thinking rookie five years
interesting yeah I remember analyzing
those 65 King 65 Rook takes A6
so this is also very likely to go to
some tourists as well yeah exactly
through K5 this is what I was talking
about just now so here I take on H5 xc2
and either I can take on H4 and play
this a really unpleasant end game where
I can keep the pawn Rook C5
which one do you think gives it better
winning chances
um
honestly I was considering playing Rook
C5 during the game because I can always
take this spot yeah you can always go
through this position yeah there's some
really uh the recent games were white
one descent game pretty easily I have
lost the sun game before yeah it's
definitely difficult
so H4 yeah he won Rook V2 this is
definitely and rookie one it's a really
nice move
and here we're wondering because you
took on A6 immediately and we were
wondering did you calculate it until 11
because it looks like Rook F6 is kind of
unpleasant shank to give if King G5
[Music]
I thought Rook takes A6 was a pretty
easy win okay interested how the
computer defense
uh I think how does the computer defend
I think it's just uh yeah but I thought
this is a win for you because you have
the F Pawn I thought this was the win
too so King G5 Rook C5 check
King G6 let's say go C4 yeah
King H6 Rook C8
King G5 C5 oh yeah it was there's this
uh amazing idea that
oh but okay okay no no one is finding
this over the world that's insane
oh it's so concrete because
because my pod has to be on C5 yeah yeah
it has to be the same because okay
finding this over the board is just
impossible yeah I thought it was
completely winning after 66. yeah we
also thought that Utah this position
because there would be one there's no
fight no oh not this yeah yeah without
like this position you thought it's a
win because uh in that uh if you pushed
the pawn all the way like we're looking
at here
I guess we were saying like this
position yeah
it's really cool yeah because like the
computer also just drops we're trying to
figure out why and then it's just this
crazy idea
but instead rugby one was if I play a C6
instead of allowing stalemate
now uh so here here oops not that so
here's his sixth note with that then
yeah
but I think this one
so I can H2 F4
I guess I'm way too slow
oh it's also still made again F5 King H1
F6 all right just H2 F7
but do I have to
can I do this
I have King E2
I cannot move this check
can I no I cannot oh yeah check I'll
check and then you take the pawn game
King's two four Yeah well yeah this was
a fascinating end game well is this
thing game actually drawn if based on
this
I do
oh I like this whole end yeah
let me find this like the sun game yeah
so Rook C2 Rook C6 King G5 if I sit with
Rook C4 I'm just King G6
yeah there's not really because F3 I
assume they go H3
uh maybe I would try something like this
because I I understand it's a draw but
it's very difficult still I mean I'm
gonna attack the H Pawn
I mean maybe if you reach this kind of
position right if you're already here
your opponent can find H3 but just to
think he probably also thought that this
is also with h3c6
uh I guess Rook C1
engage to HG King G2 and I think oh and
we can go to E6 uh
one time I thought that maybe I hide
oh okay I think this is just one pound
yeah
I hide here too or this is bad
no here you just push this one right
this doesn't work out
okay so so instead of Rook takes A6 a
rook F6 check please
uh I'm not
I'm not here yet usually
because you have to go H3 not to get me
because F4 is actually a very strong
throat so H2 G3
and then just try it and we want to
engage two well
I mean this in unnecessary to calculate
because Rook A6 seems so completely
winning yeah I think if yeah because
there's no way you can find this stuff
I don't know this still made idea you
can't yeah there's no way you can find
it yeah unless someone Terraria not
really an endgame you'd ever analyze
with H5 H4 yeah
and then everything that happened was
very yeah this is you just pick up the
ponds and once you pick up the stones
yeah this was very nice because you just
get to keep both parts yes I didn't feel
like calculating so yeah yeah nice very
nice Victor and yesterday uh you tried
oh yes and who would you play tomorrow
uh easier tomorrow and you'll be playing
with the black pieces well
congratulations on your win very nice
end game and we hope to see you back
here again after many Victors thank you